congratulations on the nomination by the
way very much critics you never know
which way it's gonna go and and they
really do homes they said you're one of
the best of the year how does that feel
it feels pretty special I'll be honest
I'm not used to this so I'm uh I'm
thrilled great company and um just gonna
have a good time I wasn't mean to share
this night with Christina because she
said she's going to be here she says
she's Miss nervous but she's gonna be
here to celebrate uh well uh we'll be
we'll be here to comfort each other as
we always do we did it the last three or
four years on set and I'm proud of her
I'm proud of what she's accomplished and
really excited to be sharing the night
with her now do you binge the show like
the rest of us at home like whenever it
was right yeah I binged it like a super
fan yeah so I ate it all up really fast
and then I'm like oh man I fast forward
past my parts never mind I even played
the intro like I just keep watching it
um what's it been like to get this kind
of love from not just the critics but
also audiences it's really nice I'll be
honest yeah yeah it's good I mean you
know I'm not I'm really not used to this
kind of thing so I'm just I'm enjoying
it and I feel really grateful and
fortunate to be included with everybody
I'm surprised by that because you've
been a part of a lot of projects that
have really resonated with people you
know yeah yeah very lucky yeah very very
lucky well good luck tonight very much
thank you James you have fun too
[Music]
foreign